all right
all right
that's 15 that was the number he does it
oh it's cold now we did that was it
that was it 15 points
50 I told the governor I told the
governor on June 2nd the Two of Us in
Orlando in the green room I said you're
gonna win by 15 points he laughed in my
face all right Governor DeSantis
foreign
people I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben
report it's November 10 2022 we are live
streaming on YouTube Rumble and Blaze TV
uh we are a little later in the day no
you have not had some sort of medical
emergency we actually are a little later
in the day we are rolling at 1 30 p.m
Eastern just for today this is a
one-time deal uh this morning I was on
the Patrick Bet David podcast which is
up in Fort Lauderdale so I had to drive
up there we thought maybe we weren't
going to do it because there was a
hurricane a bruin or a coming but it
kind of went a little more North made it
work over there and then I know a few of
you are wondering what happened
yesterday we were we thought we were
gonna do a later show yesterday because
we were on our way back from Tampa after
the big election night uh over at uh
DeSantis HQ at the Tampa Convention
Center but we got back here after about
a four and a half hour drive and then we
thought we were preparing for a
hurricane and I sort of felt like
everybody my team included me included
and you included needed like a day off
of politics I doubt that many of you
took a day off of politics but
nonetheless we are back in studio today
and we're going to recap what happened
some of it is very very very very good
some of it ain't great uh but it is what
it is we're still alive we're still here
we're going to talk a lot about all of
it we'll get into some of the numbers
and also some of it hasn't even been
completed yet for those of you that are
not paying attention at home and some of
you have to move on you have lives and
jobs and kids and other things to do uh
Arizona the gubernatorial race and the
senate race have not been decided yet
Nevada the senate race is still up I
mean this this endless day after day a
voting situation it's just or of
counting the votes uh is just enough you
know the irony of course is here in
Florida where the the results were very
clean and clear and quick it's not just
because DeSantis won by so much it's
because they cleaned up the process they
made it a very very transparent process
I don't know if you heard this but on
Election Day in the afternoon on Tuesday
the feds wanted to come in and audit
some of the Florida voting centers and
DeSantis said no it's like you guys
don't have any reason to be here and we
don't need you here uh we did everything
clean here and even the Democrats what
few Democrats are left here in Florida
and the Charlie Chris campaign and
everything else nobody's running around
going there was voter fraud or anything
else like we cleaned up we cleaned it up
we have a traceable
period from the ballots to where they're
counted and everything else and and it's
good and it's clean and that's what we
should be replicating across the country
we should probably also be replicating
across the country uh some of the
results that we got here in Florida so
that's what we'll be talking about uh
real quick guys let me talk to you about
expressvpn uh you all know that
expressvpn protects your privacy and
security online but here's something you
might not know you can also use
expressvpn to unlock movies and shows
that are only available in other
countries if you're like me and you've
run out of stuff to watch on Netflix I
can only watch Seinfeld so many times
this will change your world uh this
whole week I've been using expressvpn to
binge on The Office UK Edition it's so
simple you just fire up the expressvpn
app change your location to the UK
refresh Netflix and that's it expressvpn
lets you control where you want sites to
think you're located you can choose from
almost 100 different countries so just
imagine all the Netflix libraries you
can go to through but it's not just
Netflix of course expressvpn works with
any streaming service Hulu BBC iPlayer
YouTube you name it it also works on all
your devices phones media consoles Smart
TVs and more so you can watch what you
want on the big screen or on the go so
if you want to get access to hundreds of
new shows go to expressvpn.com Ruben
right now and you can get an extra three
months of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com Reuben expressvpn.com
Ruben to me so all right so let's start
with the good stuff and really there was
a lot of good stuff yes without question
the massive red wave that so many
predicted did not happen dare I say
allow me to quote myself but I kept
saying all along while I think it is
going to happen you never know what is
going to happen and you cannot count
your chickens before they hatch and
clearly there was some chickens being
counted before they were hatched by the
main mainstream punditry and also as I
just mentioned because we don't know the
Arizona and Nevada Senate situation
specifically that's leaving a lot of
this in the balance I mean if it comes
out that Blake Masters wins in Arizona
and that Adam lacks all
also the Republican wins in Nevada it's
like that's a kind of that's at least a
red Whipple a red Ripple Ripple uh and
also Herschel Walker who is going into
uh going to be in a runoff with Rafael
Warnock so first I really want to focus
on the good stuff because there is a lot
of good stuff and most of it is
emanating right out of the Free State of
Florida and of course as a viewer of
this show that should not surprise you
but I think it's worth reiterating some
of this stuff because we now have the
blueprint for winning and the blueprint
for winning is focusing on freedom is
fighting the woke is directly and
cleanly and clearly clearly stating what
you're going to do fighting giant
corporations like Disney fighting for
parental rights like the model here
worked and this perhaps is what
Republicans and conservatives and
disgruntle liberals and everything else
that are all over the country right now
that are not happy because if you're in
New York and you voted for zeldin and he
did an incredible job and it was way
closer than most people thought and I
honestly thought it was possible and
they got pretty damn close and New York
is going to flip a couple seats to
Republicans so good things did even
happen in New York but if you're there
and you're not happy with it you can
move on you can move to Florida maybe
zeldon should come down here and work
for uh for DeSantis that would be
something but anyway so we're going to
talk about that and then we'll talk
about what what else can be done what
else can be done and how much we should
all care if you're a Floridian how much
should you care about the governor of
Arizona or if you're a New Yorker how
much should you care about a senator in
Florida or whatever it might be so let's
start with a little bit of the media
reaction because it became very clear
very early on in the night that Florida
something really really special was
happening in Florida the people over at
the televised mental institution of
MSNBC uh were not happy about that we
just got my I'm told we just got
Miami-Dade this is a big one in Florida
let's take a look at okay this we got
the yeah so let's put this in some
perspective Miami-Dade County has two
and three quarter million people in 2016
this was a democratic County by 30
points Hillary Clinton won this County
by 30 points Miami-Dade is 70 percent
Hispanic it began shifting to the to the
Republicans in 2020 Donald Trump only
lost it by seven and look at this in the
mail-in and early vote which again tends
to be more democratic friendly Marco
Rubio the Republican is outright leading
in Miami-Dade County by seven points
over Val deming's Democratic Challenger
in the gubernatorial race uh
interestingly we don't have numbers from
Miami-Dade County hi there I'm not they
popped up for a second was that it I was
no I flipped up to Broward to try to
reset it to see if it came in
all right so they were having some
technical stuff too uh but you can even
see there I think his name's Steve
kornacki his uh his reaction he's not
happy when he see these numbers but
that's all right uh the reason I'm
really showing you that is to to point
out the truly incredible reversal that
has happened right here in Miami-Dade
and uh I am sitting in a room with four
voters of Miami-Dade four new voters in
Miami-Dade uh all who obviously voted uh
for Ron DeSantis and I assume voted
Republican but whatever you guys did on
the other things is up to you and
including for governorship
um it's incredible Hillary won
Miami-Dade which is thought of as really
a blue Speck in an otherwise really
purple State up to now now Florida is
very red obviously uh but she won it by
30 points last time now DeSantis won it
by 11. that is so huge it is such a
crazy flip and I think it is indicative
of something much wider that is
happening largely in the Latino I don't
want to say latinx the Latino community
in the United States and that actually
beared out in some other polls and in
some other results we've got a little
more from MSNBC figuring out what was
happening with Florida
if there's any single results or any
single Trend that's evident thus far
that surprised you the most tonight
obviously all of us looking at this
stuff and hearing both sides make their
projections you sort of weigh everything
based on what you know and what you can
view yourself but as somebody who's been
inside these kinds of campaigns what has
struck you as legitimately unpredictable
in tonight's results well first of all
the Divergence between Florida which you
know can't sugarcoat a disaster for the
Democrats
the interesting of course the way they
frame it it's a disaster for the
Democrats right you might want to say
it's a huge win for the Republicans but
obviously they're on the other side of
this thing but that shouldn't have been
a surprise for anybody you know in the
cold open that we showed you there uh I
mentioned as I'm talking to Liz wheeler
and they're throwing in the the results
live on June it was June 2nd it was our
last tour stop we were in Orlando and I
was sitting backstage with the governor
for about 10-15 minutes and mostly he
wanted to talk about baseball we weren't
even talking about politics and I said
to him you know Governor you're gonna
you're gonna win this thing by 15 points
and he laughed he laughed in my face and
he said six or seven would be great six
or seven would be great he ended up
winning by 20. it should not be a
surprise if if those people that are on
MSNBC had been on the ground here and
meeting all of the new the refugees who
are here now who are proud for
Floridians meeting all of the people
whose businesses stayed open whose kids
kept going to school who weren't forced
to ask and everything else this result
would have been pretty obvious I mean 20
is bananas extraordinary but it's
because of good competent governance
look obviously I like DeSantis I think
he is a decent human being I think he's
done the right things but mostly what
people voted for here was freedom and
we're going to play a couple clips from
his uh his speech in a moment when he's
talking about Freedom he's not saying
that government can do this for you and
we'll give you this and we need more
money to do that it literally is just
about keeping the the basic guard rails
of society as far away from your life as
possible not that there are no guard
rails but they're as far away as
possible so that you can live as you see
fit that is the ethos that has now been
really etched in to the situation right
here in Florida and that is what must
spread across to as many states as
possible because some states that we
thought were going to flip did not and I
think we'll we'll get into a bit about
that in just a second let me talk to you
guys about Cozy Earth real quick are you
looking to score a few extra points by
giving the perfect gift this holiday
season I've got two great ideas certain
to have family and friends bragging
about how thoughtful you are and they
are both from cozy Earth the brand with
thousands of five star reviews including
mine first cozy Earth luxury bedding
Iona set of their sheets and you can't
believe how soft they are they really
are they're not only super soft but
they're made from the finest premium
viscous from highly sustainable bamboo
that makes the that makes them naturally
temperature regulating so so you'll
sleep comfortably year round I sure do
and second anything from their luxurious
loungewear collection including soft and
stylish bamboo pajamas joggers tees and
more while you're there check out their
premium plush and Waffle bath towels
they'll you'll love those too and every
cozy Earth bedding item comes in a very
cool reusable Canvas Bag save 40 percent
now on cozy earth hurry holiday offers
and soon go to Cozy go to cozyearth.com
Dave and save 40 That's cozyearth.com
Dave and save 40 all right so let's get
into some of the other stuff and then I
Really Wanna
wrap this show up with the good news
which is you've still got some choices
whether you're watching this in Michigan
or Pennsylvania or California you still
live in the United States of America and
you've still got some ways to to better
your life if you're not feeling so great
about everything today so uh while we
did not get that Red Wave while we did
not get that red tsunami and as I said
Arizona and and Nevada still could go
red so it's like we'll see what happens
first we've got the Senate results so
far so this is so far because Arizona
and Nevada and Pennsylvania oh sorry not
Pennsylvania Georgia are still up in the
air right now it is GOP 48 and Democrats
46. uh so let's show you first I mean
this one is just the crazy one
Pennsylvania Pennsylvania
voted for John fetterman
50.8 of the vote to Dr Oz 40
6.8 come back to me for just a second on
this one look this one I I said to my
guys when we were driving to uh to Tampa
that that Pennsylvania was the one that
worried me I you know I didn't spend
much time talking about the
gubernatorial situation there uh Jay
Shapiro uh Democrat he won he's sort of
like an Obama clone if you watch him
speak he has all the mannerisms of Obama
he's young he sort of looks looks right
for the part uh and he was going against
Doug mastriano I had a feeling Shapiro
was going to win I didn't Focus much on
that race and also the truth is you know
if you don't live in a specific State
you shouldn't care that much about
someone else's gubernatorial races right
the whole system was set up to be that
you wouldn't have to care about those
things you should care about someone
else's Senate races because the Senate
makes decisions over your life
regardless of where you live but whether
Carrie Lake ends up winning in Arizona
or not while that would be nice while I
would like that for the citizens of
Arizona and I think she would be far
better than Katie Hobbs obviously it
doesn't affect me that much here in
Florida Blake master winning does
because Blake votes on bills that then
affect the entire nation okay you guys
got it the the Pennsylvania situation uh
obviously they first off their voting
situation is very bizarre they had a ton
of early mail-in ballots the Democrats
were really really pushing to get
mail-in ballots in before the debate
because they knew how poorly fetterman
was going to do in the debate and I
think you can objectively say I don't
know that anyone that would be
considered remotely honest would say
that fetterman did a decent job in that
debate he mumbled and stumbled he'd said
good night right at the beginning I mean
it was just terrible and then more and
more of these interviews came out and he
was just awful now I get why some people
would not like Dr Oz right I I was
really coming around on him I think I've
met him I think he is a decent guy as a
disaffected liberal I thought his
trajectory to becoming like a solid
Republican it seemed that through line
that I know a little something about
seemed very clean and clear to me and if
nothing else what my my general feeling
was the average person will look at
these two people
they will think hey if I live in
Philadelphia or in the suburbs like the
crime really has gotten out of control
the the drugs have gotten out of control
like who really can fix this stuff while
fetterman's mostly focused on releasing
hardcore criminals like Oz probably will
be better so look it makes all the sense
in the world that Oz would have won but
he didn't and and it was you know about
a five-point differential which
Pennsylvania man like I I don't know
what to tell you if you're in
Pennsylvania right now and you got this
you got Jay Shapiro who's just you know
he's basically a progressive Governor
now and you have Federman as your
Senator if you're in Pennsylvania like
you got to think about what you want to
do with your life because I don't think
things are going to get better there
anytime soon uh Georgia is now super
interesting and is going to be a runoff
so Raphael Warnock the Democrat
incumbent
49.4 percent of the vote at Herschel
Walker the Republican uh what was that
48.5 so they're within the margin that's
going to boot this to a runoff election
which Phoenix what did you tell me right
before is that December 6th December 6th
uh so we've got about a month now where
everyone's going to be focused on
Georgia it's another one of those things
where it's like another special election
we need more elections blah blah blah
what will be interesting about the
runoff there is that Brian Kemp did
defeat election deniers Stacy Abrams so
Abrams is out the Republican incumbent
Governor did win now you would imagine
that a certain amount of people they
just vote for a ticket right so you end
up you just go Republican Republican
Republican or Democrat Democrat Democrat
so it might hurt Herschel Walker that
the guy who won who got more votes at
the top of the ticket is not on the
ballot when they do this uh this next
round so so we shall see what happens
there uh the other one that's
interesting right now it has not been
fully confirmed yet uh is the laxalt
masto situation in Nevada which right
now it's at 49.4 percent for Adam laxalt
who actually was I don't know if you
know if I've mentioned it on the show I
think it was Ron desantis's college
roommate and masto is at 47.6 they're
doing some more counting on that right
now so we will see I mean I don't know
why it does seem very odd to me that in
other countries they can figure out
their elections day of we have all the
technology in the world right we used to
be able to do it all day of it's called
election day but in certain places we
seem unable to do it speaking of certain
places we seem unable to do it Arizona
Mark Kelly this is now like changing on
the Fly because they're they're
announcing things literally it seems
like every half hour at this point but
Mark Kelly Democrat incumbent 51.4 Blake
Masters at 46.4 but they are saying that
these new batches are that are being
counted now apparently there's about 800
000 votes outstanding
and it does sound like they come from
more red areas so that one could flip
one that did actually get finalized on
Election night JD Vance uh beat uh Tim
Ryan that's
53-46 and we're just going to do one
more one or two more of these and then
we'll get out of the numbers uh Marco
Rubio I mean I just had to you know we
knew he was going to win but but he
absolutely crushed uh Val demings by
about 16 points a little over 16 points
just absolutely spectacular so the the
results so far the Democrats now have
184 seats in the House Republicans have
207 you need 218 for the majority uh and
there's uh there's a bunch of seats I
think around 30 something 34 so that are
being worked out right now because they
were too close to call and on the
governor's side of things uh the
Democrats now have 22 governorships and
the Republicans have 24. Okay so let's
just pause on it for a second because I
this is you know people watch Cable News
on election night or after election
night they get obsessed with the numbers
and obsessed with who did this there
their white working class here and these
people get a let's just move past all
that for just a moment
I want to focus on the blueprint
and what we can do going forward and the
blueprint as I said is what happened
here in Florida you know the the other
conversation that's starting to happen
right now and we knew this we knew we
were going to get to this conversation
at some point is where does Trump fit
into this right because Trump backed a
guy like Oz Oz lost Trump was a huge
backer of Carrie Lake she at this moment
is losing Trump was a big backer of
Blake Masters At This Moment is losing
those could flip so right now there's a
feeling like the truck the really Trump
trump people Doug mastriano in in
Pennsylvania uh that they did not do
that well but what did do well
competence in governorship and
Leadership and that really is the the
DeSantis message so there's definitely
going to be some tension there as I said
the media wants there to be some tension
there
um but I think a lot of people are
talking about it not I think I know a
lot of people are talking about I'm
getting a lot of calls and texts I was
on Patrick David's show this morning
like everyone wants to talk about like
what happens to the Republicans now in
this Trump DeSantis thing and it's it's
gonna it's gonna play out it's gonna
play out probably somewhat privately uh
but it's going to play out uh publicly
as well uh obviously oh the other one
that I didn't even mention at all is
Texas Beto O'Rourke got crushed by Greg
Abbott so it's like Beto you got to go
away now you lost twice Stacey Abrams
you got to go away now like you guys
just get out of here get going uh all
right we got one more ad for you then
we'll get to it let me talk to you about
comicoto knives uh you know it's time to
up your knife game with kamikoto knives
using traditional techniques kamikoto
crafts beautiful knives using steel
Source from Japan each blade is made
with techniques that have been honed and
perfected by generations of knife Smiths
they come in beautiful heavy duty Ash
wood boxes and every blade is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel Edge kamikoto knives can
achieve a wickedly sharp edge the kind
you just can't get with other knives
these cut through these are cut through
your rib eye like butter sharp commit
code knives are used by several chefs
working at Michelin star restaurants
around the world they make amazing gifts
that come in beautiful boxes you can
maintain each knife's edge with one of
kamikoto's sharpening wet stones and
like I said they're so confident in
their product that each and every knife
comes with a lifetime guarantee if you
go ahead and buy now Kami code is
offering you an extra fifty dollars off
site wide on top of their Black Friday
sale go to comicoto.com Reuben and use
the offer code Reuben for an extra fifty
dollars off
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o.com
reubencomicoto.com
Reuben all right
let's continue uh Brian Camp as I said
in Georgia won Greg Abbott in Texas won
so some of the Fortified red States
stayed red but as I keep bringing this
back to him a little bit of a broken
record today but just bear with me
because it's important we have the
blueprint now I get it there's a certain
amount of people in America that just
want more government I think maybe that
was my biggest takeaway more than
anything else it's like if you didn't
wake up
this would be my biggest personal
takeaway I mean this about me
um that if you didn't wake up it's so
hard to believe I was so red pilled over
the last couple years I I was so focused
on freedom and getting the government
off my back and not being injected with
things if I didn't want to and not
listening to bureaucrats tell me that I
had to wear a diaper on my face and all
of the other stuff that I think perhaps
maybe my blind spot and I always talk we
always we all have little blind spots
mine was that we want everybody to be
red pilled alongside of us and I think
that we just have to accept that there's
a certain amount of people that refuse
to see the world as it is rather than
how they wish it to be so Ben Shapiro
actually after the election had a two
tweet thread that was on this which I
responded to and I think this kind of
lays it out he said last night was not a
referendum on Democrats excellence in
governance it was a referendum on
Republicans lack of seriousness
Democrats will misread this and keep
doubling down down so if Republicans get
serious and drop the frivolous BS 2024
could look very different if
if culture War isn't frivolous [ __ ]
by the way it's key but it's the icing
on the cake of competent governance and
earning trust with voters see DeSantis
Ron and young and Glenn icing on a bag
of weird ain't gonna win you elections
so I did respond to Ben I'll get into it
in one second but what he's saying there
I think which is the key part is that we
can fight the culture War right I do
this show we're constantly fighting the
culture War the gender stuff the woke
stuff the race stuff
and that is a huge piece of it to
competently fight this but actually what
people want more is good governance I
really believe that at least at least on
the Republican side they want good
governance they want a simple system
that that does what is supposed to do
and doesn't do much beyond that so if
you have a good competent government
that is fighting the woke fighting the
the culture wars properly and then using
a winning message which I really believe
is pro-family and pro freedom and
pro-america then you can win so I
retweeted Ben and I expanded on this a
little bit
uh I said this seems right but we also
have to accept that probably 40 of the
electorate wants bigger government more
lockdowns and mandates higher taxes and
less control over their own lives
changing that reality isn't political
it's spiritual right this is something I
often talk about DeSantis has laid out
the blueprint for Effective governance
partnered with the aspirational message
of Freedom Dems know a certain amount of
people just want to be governed harder
at the end of the day if California
Pennsylvania New York want more of that
then good luck to them this is the
beauty of federalism if you woke up in
New York and you don't want your kids
injected during covet six make plans and
move and if all the freedom of Florida
is bothering you go ahead and move to
New York where you can pay more in taxes
and be assaulted on the subway America
with some American flags and that really
is what it comes down to and I and I
think that you know I'm talking about
the blueprint as my message today but
that concept there that you have some
autonomy over your life is the most
important thing that we have As
Americans in terms of your ability to
think and act for yourself but that you
also have some choice that this blue red
map that we have all over this country
that you know most of the states don't
move that much anymore we have our
hardcore blue ones and our hardcore red
ones but don't forget Florida was pretty
damn purple and flipping back and forth
for a long time now it is as red as it
could possibly be again Rhonda Sanders
won by 20 points actually I'll just
throw this up real quick the numbers
here on the the amount of people that
voted for Ron DeSantis he had over 4.6
million votes Chris had about
3.1 million you must remember the key
part of this is that Ron DeSantis won
his election in 2018 by less than 40 000
votes it was like 35 000 votes something
like that he almost lost that election
it was basically under one percent and
the guy that would be Governor right now
in Florida Andrew Gilliam turned out to
be a meth addict that's how close
Florida was to the precipice and then
DeSantis comes in and does it right
keeps his eye on the ball acts bravely
governs as a competent manager
and this place is working so you know
when we were uh when we were driving
back from Tampa and I had all my guys in
the car it was Connor in Phoenix and
Daphne and we were driving back and it
was like it was the morning after so it
was like we had this amazing night after
DeSantis HQ and there were thousands of
people and it was a party and it was a
celebration and it was just it was so
wonderful to be there and we're feeling
so good about Florida but then as we
were driving back you know we're looking
at all the numbers and it was like well
some of these races aren't decided how
did fetterman win
um you know that that George is going to
a runoff like they're all the you know
the wave itself didn't happen
and what I said to the guys was it's
like you know we made the decision
a year ago to move it's not easy to move
when I say this thing about the foot
vote and that you can move and that's
what Federalism is all about like I get
it it is not easy to move I think one of
the reasons that I've I've felt so good
and feel so good right now even though
the broad results weren't exactly what I
wanted is that a year ago I made a
decision to do something better for my
life and my family's life and my
co-workers and my companies and I moved
to a place that was in line with my
values so although Arizona and
Pennsylvania may be completely you know
Arizona is still up in the air but like
whether these blue states are completely
the other direction or not it's like I'm
doing the best I can to protect the
things that I care about most and I care
about America very deeply you know the
national idea of America the federal
idea of America that we are the United
States but I do think as I said in that
tweet maybe we just have to accept that
40 I mean I was sort of pulling that
number out of thin air but that x amount
of people are always going to vote
Democrat no matter what but a certain
amount of people
are brainwashed and think that the
government is their God and they think
the government is supposed to endlessly
give them things and they do honestly
believe it's racist to have a border and
they don't believe in policing and
whatever it might be but the thing is
you can choose to live in a place that
is in line with how you feel and what
your values are if you are in New York
right this moment and there's a lot of
good people in New York the fact that
zeldin did so well only lost that race
by five points and if you look at the
map we should have pulled the map up if
you look at the map of New York he won
almost all of New York it's New York
City and then sort of like the Buffalo
area but it's mostly New York
metropolitan area that he lost right
that's a concentration of a gajillion
people but if you look at the broad map
of New York it's almost all red which by
the way is very similar to the broad map
of the United States if you look at the
whole map of the United States it's
almost all red but then you have these
blips of blue you've got your blips of
Los Angeles and your blips of New York
and Austin and San Francisco but the
country they basically believes that the
country is good it believes in the
America that we are constantly fighting
for but if you are frustrated if you
live in Philly it's not going to get
better I hate to tell you you guys now
have a terrible senator who can barely
speak and barely communicate you now
have a progressive governor and it ain't
going to get better and it ain't gonna
get better uh in some of these other
places that re-elected Democrats or
flipped to the to Blue not many places
flip they either stayed blue
so you get it guys like you have a
choice in this country and I think
that's why I'm feeling very validated
like I'm not right now if I was doing
the show and we were all still in Cali
I'd be drunk I'd be under the table you
people would be crying it would not be
good you know what I'm saying but we are
all sitting here proud to be in a place
that is in line with our Valley so again
I get it it's not easy you know I
discussed this with Bill Maher you know
because he was like well I'd have to
leave if they brought mandates back but
he was like but you know I have my
houses here and my friends are here and
my show is here and it's like well some
people have nothing
so okay it's hard for rich people to
move because they have a lot of stuff
well it's hard for poor people to move
because they don't can't avoid the
freaking truck some people have elderly
grandparents in a certain place some
people have kids in school and it's hard
to you know re-socialize like we've all
got stuff
but you have a chance so every time I
tweet that out people go it ain't easy
to move
you're right it ain't easy how many
things that are worthwhile in life are
easy
very few
so why am I so proud to be here in
Florida well because freedom is here to
stay Florida was a refuge of Sanity when
the world went mad we stood as a citadel
of freedom for people across this
country and indeed across the world
we faced attacks we took the hits we
weathered the storms
but we stood our ground
we did not back down we had the
conviction to guide us and we had the
courage to lead we made promises
we made promises to the people of
Florida and we have delivered on those
promises
and so today after four years the people
have delivered their verdict freedom is
here to stay
chills up my spine man because that's
what it's all about that's what it's all
about and you know you don't become a
leader overnight it takes a long time to
do it and Ron desantis's life has led
him to this you know I was checking this
morning you know that Rhonda sandis is
44 years old he's two years younger than
me not bizarre like the guy is in his
prime and he is ready to fight and Lead
he really is ready and how did he do it
well he he was competent he was clear he
fought the bureaucrats and then when the
culture of war came here he fought back
he didn't get into the culture War for
the hell of it but when it came here and
schools were teaching young boys that
they're actually young girls and
teachers were talking about to kids
about sexuality privately and hiding it
from the parents and then when that was
rocket fueled by Disney which is one of
the biggest corporations in the world
which is HQ right here in Orlando
Florida what did he do he fought them he
fought the woke and well he brought that
up in his speech as well
we have embraced Embrace freedom
s payers and we reject woke ideology
we fight the woke in the
military we've
we've been the schools we fight the woke
and the corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die
I mean Florida is where we'll go through
that I like powerful stuff I think that
was the best speech of his life so far I
think his energy was just right
obviously the energy in the room was
electric uh nobody nobody even though I
crazily said to him he was going to win
by 15 points nobody expected the
20-point win but he stepped up there and
just knocked it out of the park as a
former baseball player would do and the
Florida Republican party it's not just
DeSantis that has the blueprint it's the
Florida Republican party and again I
know most of you watching this obviously
do not live in Florida so it's not that
you should be obsessed with Floridian
politics except that this is the way
these are the ideas that if you can
incorporate wherever you live whether
it's a red State that's teetering that
you want to get these things over or
whether you really think you can stay
and fight in a blue State and change
things these are the ideas this was a
purple State as I said this was a state
that every year
okay every time it was different every
time but now we've got a tweet from
election wizard breaking Republicans
take super majority in both chambers of
the Florida State Legislature and guess
what guys guess what
you know what there's going to be this
Florida super majority Republican super
majority and you know what you're going
to see you're going to see competency
you're going to see more tax breaks
you're going to see more infrastructure
be built you're going to see more
surpluses and then when the money is
needed it'll be used appropriately like
we did here in Hurricane Ian you're not
going to see them encroaching on more
people they're not going to be chasing
down the gays or any of those things
they're not going to be book burning
you're going to see more and more
competency so just a little bit a little
bit more on Florida just bear with me
guys because I think this is really the
takeaway this is the takeaway Jeremy
Redford who works in the administration
he said Governor Ron DeSantis won 62 of
67 counties in Florida he flipped Seven
Counties from Blue to red and even of
those remaining five counties had double
digit red shifts so this is this is just
incredible so the state the five
counties that he lost he all had huge
red shift towards which is alucha godson
Leon Broward Broward which is incredible
at 14 points and Orange County say
everything everything
shifted here and it's just just a little
more on the numbers I know I'm getting
deep in numbers today this is from The
New York Times Miami-Dade DeSantis won
by 11 points that's what we referenced
earlier on MSNBC nobody could believe it
Broward yes Chris won Broward he did but
they did he did not win it nearly the
way that they thought of and
historically uh it has been done and
then even in Palm Beach County DeSantis
won by three
it's all here guys the pieces are all
here and you know I mean it maybe maybe
I'm gonna get in trouble with some OG
Floridians but I mean it there there is
room to build here I think DeSantis next
move has to be some really big
infrastructure stuff South Florida still
has places to to build right we've got
Homestead areas it's huge it's booming
right now but there are places to build
let's build more houses let's cut that
red tape you know actually at the uh at
the party at the HQ party I met a guy a
couple you know people were coming up to
me all night long and a guy came up to
me and said that he was a contractor he
actually lived in Miami and he does
buildings here in Miami he does
commercial and residential here in Miami
but he said when when the hurricane hit
and they knew that they were gonna have
to rebuild Fort Myers and the Sanibel
Causeway and Pine Island Bridge and all
these things all of these contractors
basically went people didn't even know
what they were going to do but they took
trucks and they basically just went
across the street and state and they
tried to figure out how they could help
he said that in a normal situation that
it would have taken if this was the
Federal Government it would have taken
probably two years to rebuild that
Sanibel Causeway it was rebuilt in under
a month effectively rebuilt it's being
used right now as they're still cleaning
up down there but de Santa they said he
basically the people went to DeSantis
and they said look we can do this but
not the way a normal government does it
you must cut all the red tape we cannot
be waiting for all of this stuff you got
to just let us build and they started
building building building and they did
something that we know you all saw the
the videos and the pictures of the
destruction like they did some
incredible things and it was because the
government got out of the way not
because the government did more uh
here's just something from ye politics
that I thought was interesting DeSantis
won post-grads by seven points so he
wanted if you look here never attended
College he won attended college but
received no degree he won associate's
degree he won bachelor's degree he won
and but the one that I thought was most
interesting was this an advanced degree
after bachelor's degree such as
m-a-m-b-a-md PhD et cetera this is where
usually the Liberals win right Democrats
win with these ultra-educated sort of
Ivory Tower somewhat out of touch people
but not here in the Free State of
Florida and then of course the other big
thing was that the Latino vote really
really shifted I don't know if you know
this but we have an awful lot of Latinos
many EX well not X Cubans we have many
Cuban uh Patriots right here in the
Miami area and Venezuelans and
everything else so here's some info from
NBC oh well so this is funny so ezrael
Levant tweeted this and it's it's
referring to this NBC uh poll he said
AOC is a white person's idea of what a
Latino voter wants sorry I mean latinx
Ron DeSantis is what Latino voters
Latino voters actually want and you can
see Cubans moved just a tiny bit towards
DeSantis Puerto Ricans tremendously 19
points and other Latinos 16 points
yeah
that shouldn't surprise you and latinx
isn't a thing it's just not a thing uh
by the way uh this is a tweet from Scott
Pressler who did an absolutely great job
in getting out the vote uh flipped
congratulations to congresswoman elect
Anna Paulina Luna Republicans flip
Charlie Chris seat from Blue to Red that
was in Florida District 13. so Anna
Paulina Luna has now replaced Charlie
Chris so Charlie Chris doesn't even have
a job anymore so there is does the good
news here in Florida never end it just
never ends a little bit more just
quickly on the senate race here this was
from Fox News breaking news also in the
Sunshine State the Fox News decision
desk can project Republican senator
Marco Rubio has defeated Val demings and
as I mentioned earlier it was by like 16
points and I thought Rubio he's an
excellent orator he gave quite a quite a
good speech when he was accepting two
days ago and the most important house in
the America is not the White House it's
your house
because that's where children are raised
and values are formed and principles are
are instilled
and our job is to make sure we always
protect the family
we always make it possible for parents
to do from to do for their children or
what my parents did for me and what your
parents did for you
that's the American story it changed the
world it inspired the world
and if you don't like this country
you're free to leave my office will even
help you do the Visa
you're free to leave you're free to
leave the country you're free to leave
the state he'll he'll give you the Visa
that's pretty good if you have not
watched one of my interviews with Marco
Rubio I think the first one we went into
some of his history I mean his parents
came here from Cuba his dad was a
dishwasher okay for basically no money
his son became one of the most powerful
senators and a presidential candidate in
the United States is an absolutely
incredible story it's a type of story
that only happens in the United States
but it's not just DeSantis and it's not
just Rubio Maria Elvira Salazar won in
Miami-Dade she is a Republican and a
Latina don't tell AOC we won thank you
to all of my amazing supporters 2022 is
the year of the Hispanic Republicans and
here's a bit of her victory speech this
election proves what Ronald Reagan
famously said the Latinos are
Republicans they just don't know it
until tonight because 2022 has been the
year of the Hispanic Republicans okay so
we're going to throw to some locals
comments in just a moment we've got a
great call close for you uh but I think
you see why I did Today's Show the way I
did uh we can always get lost in every
little battle and worrying about every
little thing and you know in politics
you're going to win some and you're
going to lose some the irony is as I sit
here right at this very moment because
Nevada and Georgia and Arizona because
those Senate seats are still up in the
up for grabs it's like the Red Wave
still may happen we actually don't know
but either way by no estimation was a
disaster and even if it was a freaking
disaster all over the country you always
need a bright spot you need as Jordan
Peterson talks about you need that star
in the distance to look to so that you
can go towards that well it is here in
Florida so I know I'm heavy-handed when
it comes to Florida and I talk about
Rhonda Sanchez a lot and I talk about
what we're doing a lot but I think in
some ways it was for me just for me
personally what happened here two days
ago and what is happening here every
second of every day is a culmination of
of the ideas that I've fought for and
for the for the
the fact that I picked up my life and
the life of all these people that that
I'm involved with and we came here and
did it and if you do that you feel the
rewards of that right you get your just
dessert you really can get your just
dessert and I think all of you and I'm
seeing a lot of you in the locals
Community because I was asking about it
yesterday and today uh are thinking
about making some moves many of you have
made Moves I've got an awful lot of
people that reach out to me that have
moved to Florida but people that are
moving to Texas and a whole bunch in
Tennessee and elsewhere but really think
about it like we have to accept we have
to accept that a certain amount of
people just want more government uh you
know the other thing that sits behind
all of this is that this this Young
Generation now unless we can red pill
them really fast they're being born in a
world where they accept government
mandates where they accept putting masks
on and when they can go to school and
when they can and being online all the
time and being given all this stuff
that's not a great uh indicator of
future Freedom right so so we have a lot
of work to do
um for me personally doing that work
from a place that's uh in line with my
values is is important and I'm going to
keep fighting for it here and hopefully
we can extend it elsewhere a couple
comments from the locals Community
California runaway great name says this
election has made me so thankful I left
California more so than ever you know
it's funny we didn't even play one clip
during any of the debates of Gavin
Newsom we knew Which Way Cali was going
to go it wants more of it it's not going
to turn around in California and that's
the model for blue
so you've got the Newson California
model for blue and you've got the
DeSantis Florida model for red and you
have to decide which one of those things
that you want to pick in DeSantis
actually performed better in Florida
than Newsom did in California which is
also pretty amazing Marty says New
Yorker on Jesse Warner's show yesterday
said New Yorkers would vote for Satan if
he was a Democrat yeah I mean this is
the thing if these people have been blue
pilled to that point if they if they are
okay with what has happened to New York
City the idea that New York City I mean
this is the crazy part when I mentioned
before that New York City if you look at
the map you guys should Google it after
maybe we'll put it up on tomorrow's show
or something but if you look at the map
of New York how it voted I'm telling you
it's all red with these two little blips
basically of blue and the main blip is
that New York City metro area so think
about it New York City which just had
all the years of Bill de Blasio a
socialist that ruined New York City then
they bring in Eric Adams he's been awful
too and then they get hochul after
having Cuomo so it's all Democrat run
right and for whatever reason these
people in these cities they just always
think more Democrats higher taxes sure
it doesn't matter if the rich people
leave and take all their resources and
then we have to you know squeeze the
other people sure it doesn't matter if
it's not safe let's keep defunding the
police let's not treat the blue well the
blue meaning the back the blue the
police officers
but they seem to want more and more so
at some point like when the rubber met
the road for me and Cali it was after
the
the recall I had had it I got audited by
the state I was just done I was done and
done and done and then I moved to a
place that is free and guess what I got
more change in my pocket too because
there's no state income tax here but
that was certainly not why I did it
um you got to get to that point in your
own life if you're frustrated today
Chuck says DeSantis set the blueprint to
winning this country back yes he did and
as I said earlier this is where and
obviously we're going to talk a lot
about it over the next couple weeks we
have to figure out where Trump figures
fits into this thing or I should say
Trump has to figure out where he fits
into this thing DeSantis and competent
governance fighting the woke
maintaining a belief in America
DeSantis is just knocking it out of the
park I like Trump you know I like Trump
most of you like Trump I voted for Trump
there's many situations in which I would
still vote for Trump I like his kids I
think he believes in America all of that
stuff but what is best for the country
right now I'm actually
I'm actually not even totally sure what
the answer is but it needs to be worked
out it needs to be worked out and and
again I don't even know that DeSantis
wants to run but I know what DeSantis
represents if we are going to be a free
country in the future is what the right
thing is and and also the other part of
this is and I think this is something
that Trump really has to think about so
so Trump or any Trump people if you're
watching take this one to Heart
how many new voters can Trump bring in
right at this point how many new people
will be like you know I've actually come
around and I like Trump or were young
and couldn't vote and suddenly he'll be
like I'm into trump it that it seems
like he may have hit his ceiling on that
the problem with Trump is that a certain
amount of people who by the end of four
years of Biden even if he makes it that
long
will not be interested in voting because
they'll be so depressed just Democrats
that'll have seen the nonsense but
suddenly if you make Trump the opponent
probably 5 million of them appear out of
nowhere so Trump's sort of at his
ceiling with his people but then you
could bring back a whole bunch of people
who probably wouldn't vote if DeSantis
has proven one thing it's that DeSantis
can get new voters to vote Republican
look at those Latino numbers I just
showed you look at the quite literally I
think over 300
000 people moved here from other states
we'll get the numbers on it eventually
they'll start coming out but you have to
imagine two-thirds minimum if not if not
significantly more voted for DeSantis
how many people in your life do you know
who are not traditional Republicans who
have said to you you know I'm kind of
over the Trump thing but I could vote
for DeSantis
like these are all things that are they
just have to be discussed they just have
to be discussed and we can figure it out
uh all right guys we got a great cold
close for you so hang tight for one
second as always uh subscribe if you
have not on rumble.com reubenreport and
if you want to play along during the
live show and get some more of my uh
some my food pictures and baby pictures
and much more it's
reubenreport.locals.com Michael Shermer
my interview with Michael Shermer great
stuff on conspiracies and everyone's a
conspiracy theorist now because they all
turn out to be true uh if you like any
of that kind of stuff and UFOs and all
that you'll enjoy my interview with
Michael Shermer we leave you with yeah
you guessed it Ron DeSantis see you
tomorrow
courage isn't a brilliant Dash a daring
deed in a moment's Flash
it isn't an instantaneous thing born of
Despair with a sudden spring
it isn't a creature of flickered Hope
on the final tug at some slipping rope
but it's something deep in the soul of
man that is working always to serve some
plan
courage isn't the last resort and the
work of life for the game of sport
it isn't a thing that a man can call at
some future time when he's up to four
if he hasn't it now he will have it not
and the strain is great and the pace is
hot
for who would strive for a distant goal
must always have courage within his soul
[Music]
Carriage isn't a dazzling light that
flashes and passes away from sight
it's a slow unwavering ingrained trait
with the patience to work and the
strength to wait it's part of a man when
his skies are blue it's part of him when
he has work to do the brave man never is
free of it he has it when there is no
need of it
courage was never designed for show it
isn't a thing that can come and go it's
written in Victory and defeat and every
trial a man may meet
it is part of his hours his days and his
years back of his Smiles behind his
tears
courage is more than a daring deed it is
the breath of life and a strong man's
Creed
foreign